I really appreciate it oh this is
exciting I don't think I've ever had a
conversation as long as we're about to
have I've been listening to the
happiness hypothesis over the last few
days and I really really enjoy it I'm
really enjoying it it's really
fascinating stuff man
but one thing I wanted to talk about
because we're talking about it right
before we got started was what's
happening with Peter Bogosian at
Portland State University
yeah for folks who don't know the story
he and I forget his two colleagues
challenge lemon rose and yeah James
Lindsay yeah they released these fake
papers on like homoeroticism and rape
culture in dog parks and just really
propriety stuff papers that almost like
an article from the onion and some of
them not only did they get peer reviewed
and accepted into these journals but
they got loud it as being these amazing
one did one guy yeah yeah and now he's
getting in trouble that's right yeah and
we were just talking about it and I just
would love to know your thoughts as a
professor like what oh sure yeah so you
know for those who don't know I guess
most your listeners probably do but you
know it was called the grievance studies
hoax yeah because and this is one of the
big issues going on in the Academy I
hope we'll talk about is you know what
does it take to have good scholarship
and and the argument is that in some
fields as long as you hate the right
things and use the right words you'll
get published and that's not scholarship
that's activism and so these three these
three people who did this hoax they were
trying to show that that's the case and
so they wrote these papers one of them
was actually a section of mine Kumpf yes
and they just substituted in something
about feminism for Nazism something like
that and I don't remember that one
actually got I think it's it at any rate
the point is they were trying to show
that this is some of these field to me
Academy are not really about scholarship
they're just about showing that you hate
the right things their activism and so
there's no way to break in within those
closed world so they did a time-honored
thing they did a hoax they published
they submitted these papers they made up
fake names and and a lot of them got
accepted and now what's happening is
that the universe at Portland State
University which is only one of the
three is that it is a
professor he's a system professor so
he's not tenured you know of course the
he has a lot of enemies and of course I
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes but it looks like some of them
wanted him investigated for violating
the IRB the internal review board
because the claim is they fabricated
data because one of the paper says I
inspected the genitals of ten thousand
dogs in the dog park you know it's like
obviously absurd yeah and he said you
know in 63 percent of the of the
attempted hump because the thing-thing
of the article was that the idea that
you know you go to a dog park and you
see dogs humping each other and they
were interpreting this as rape as doggy
rape and so he's got all these note you
know fake numbers in there so is that
fraud isn't that data fraud and if you
read so I'm writing a letter for a lot
of us are now writing letters in support
of Pelusium thank you for doing that
but if you read the they at his
university committee was impaneled and
they looked at the literal definition of
data fabrication and it's possible that
he does fall under that but the point of
this whole thing is so it's not like ant
weigh in on whether or not technically
but but these rules are put in place to
prevent the corruption of the scientific
record and what he was doing was not
going to corrupt the scientific record
it was done to correct it we're doing it
to show that there's a huge problem and
then they were going to unveil it so the
question is is the university going to
interpret this in the worst possible in
a narrows possible way and thereby make
fools of themselves look like
laughingstocks or are they going to use
some common sense and recognize this for
what it was it wasn't data fabrication
it wasn't a fraud
it was an expose that's right yeah and I
hope that they come to their senses and
they do have a point if I'm going to be
completely objective about data
fabrication I mean technically I mean
maybe they could have written that paper
without saying that they actually tested
ten thousand genitals of you but what's
really important I think is that they
recognize that regular people are paying
attention to this now people that aren't
involved in this very insulated world
and they're going this is crazy like
imagine if your children are going
and your children children are being
taught at this school that's willing to
accept this kind of nonsense like this
what what happened at Evergreen State
University is another example of that
it's right it's incredibly damaging to
them as a university I mean their their
enrollment is significant on it down
that's right their funding is in real
big trouble and it's a real bad
situation for them and if you talk to
Brett Weinstein it was a wonderful place
just a few years ago when he was
teaching there that's right and it's
gotten crazier and crazier on these
campuses to the point where nonsense is
never being is not being questioned at
all it's just being accepted as just
some some is it's almost like some
religious dogma that you have to follow
that's right
so the wait I think the way to make
sense of all of this is you have to
always look at what game is being played
so human beings evolved in small-scale
societies we have all kinds of abilities
to function in those small scale
societies one of those is religious
worship we're very good at making
something sacred and circling around it
another is war we're very good at
forming teams to fight the other side
and we love that so much we create
sports and you know video game battles
with team vs. team so there's all these
different games you can play and the
truth-seeking game is a was a really
special one in a weird one and we're not
very good at it as individuals and in my
view the genius of university is that it
takes people and puts them together in
ways where each person each like
scientists aren't these super rational
creatures that are you know looking to
disconfirm their own ideas no we're not
looking we want to prove our ideas we
love our ideas but a university puts us
together in a way in which you are
really motivated to disprove my ideas
and I'm motivated to disprove yours you
put us together we cancel out each
other's confirmation biases so the
truth-seeking game is a very special
game that can only be played in a very
special institution with special norms
okay so we're doing this for you know my
whole time in academia our to grad
school in 1987 at the University of
Pennsylvania
and then just in the last few years it's
like some people are playing this really
different game and it's like if you know
if I'm playing tennis and I hit the ball
to you like we're in a seminar class
mm-hm I give you a question I challenge
you you come back and we go back and
forth and in the process we learned so
that's like kind of like playing tennis
so I'm doing this and then suddenly like
someone tackles me like what that you
don't do that in tennis no no but
they're playing football you see and in
football it's a much rougher game and
you're trying to destroy the others I'm
not really in football but I'm saying
yes you know it's a and so as norms of
combat come in and what I mean by it is
political combat as some people within
universities see that what we're doing
here is not seeking truth we're trying
to fight fascism where we're trying to
defeat conservatism or we're trying to
fight racism or whatever some sort of
political goal and these games are
completely incompatible and so that's
why this madness has erupted where you
see professors saying something maybe
it's a little provocative I'm going back
to Socrates that was kind of the point
was to provoke and you see these bizarre
reactions emotional reactions groups
organized to demand that a professor be
fired because we're playing different
games